dice una función f x se muestra en verde
muy bien entonces tenemos nuestra
función en verde que es f x el segmento
morado corredizo puede contener una
sección de una anti derivada de la
función ya ésta le vamos a llamar f
mayúscula de x ok entonces esencialmente
lo que me está diciendo este enunciado
es que esta ventana moradita bueno más
bien esta ventana que tiene una gráfica
de una función esencialmente nos dice
que su derivada debe ser algún pedazo de
esta función verde donde corresponde la
función en la ventana corrediza a efe
mayúscula de x muy bien entonces lo que
tenemos que encontrar es algún intervalo
en donde esta función al derivar la
corresponde con la parte verde que
tenemos muy bien por ejemplo tenemos
esta parte morada esta parte morada es
creciente es una recta y ésta tiene
pendiente positiva y constante así que
de entrada
tiene que buscar una pendiente es decir
que la gráfica verde sea constante y
positiva entonces si vamos avanzando nos
vemos nos damos cuenta que aquí es
constante pero aquí es negativa entonces
no nos sirve muy bien entonces podemos
seguir avanzando otra vez aquí es
constante pero es negativa sin embargo
aquí sí es positiva verdad y es
constante porque pues porque va subiendo
y es y va subiendo como una recta sin
embargo acá de este lado una vez que
llegamos a este punto máximo
ahora vamos decreciendo poco a poco
entonces su derivada no es constante y
sin embargo aquí sí lo es así que
podemos pensar que no hay solución vamos
a ver y lo tenemos correcto vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio
a ver digamos este también una función f
x misma idea muy bien entonces tenemos
que hacer que al derivar esta parte si
nos damos cuenta va creciendo verdad va
creciendo entonces tenemos que hacer que
coincida por ejemplo en esta parte va
creciendo pero después en esta parte
debe ser constante y debe ser negativa
entonces esto no nos sirve pero esto sí
probablemente esto funcione vamos a ver
también estuvo correcto muy bien ahora
tenemos un caso contrario tenemos una
función efe de equis y la función f x es
la morada la ventana corrediza ahora es
la derivada muy bien entonces tenemos la
función y queremos ver si la derivada
encaja en alguna de estos en alguno de
estos intervalos muy bien entonces la
verde ahora es la derivada vamos a ver
dice que la derivada al menos en esta
parte debe ser constante y positiva
entonces quiere decir que la función
debe crecer como una
recta entonces que pedazos crecen como
una recta solo es de verdad entonces
vamos a ver este es nuestro primer
candidato
y ahora nos dice después la función que
va decreciendo va decreciendo y que
coincide muy bien con esta verdad
decrece cada vez más y más y más
entonces esta es nuestra propuesta vamos
a ver ahí lo tienen tuvimos tres buenas
de corrido